[Musique]
[Rires]
le jour se lève
le jour se lève sur une immense plaine
recouverte de slam ses slams sont ces
habitations bâche est soutenu par
simplement quelques branchages
nous sommes dans l'immense bidonville de
bombay exactement à hamra watier il y
pleut l'eau ruisselle sur ses vaches y
les gouttes tombent sur cette terre
humide
cette eau forme des petits cratères dans
lequel viennent s'amonceler ces gouttes
d'eau jusqu'à devenir une petite flaque
la chaleur et l'humidité se mariant
rendent une atmosphère peu agréable mais
c'est une une c'est une des épices et
dans des épisodes de la vie quotidienne
de bombay les enfants commencent à se
lever il joue certains jouent au ballon
n'ayant pour ballon qu une bouteille
d'eau vide mais ils sont heureux
d'autres vont se laver se laver dans les
flaques parce qu'ils n'ont rien d'autre
et se laver dans les flaques côtoyons
avec eux les rats d'égouts et les chiens
dans les ruelles les chiens errants
cherche quelques graines et je dirais
quelques boutons pour se rassasier les
vaches sacrées quand elle
continuent leurs nuits dans les ruelles
dans les boulevards et forment des ronds
points ce qui permet une situation dans
un bois
innommable mais là aussi tu es c'est une
des scènes quotidiennes des bidonvilles
les papas quant à eux vont chercher de
quoi nourrir leur famille
il erre dans la rue les mamans quant à
elle courageuse et authentique lave un
peu les slams mais surtout vont au
marché vendre quelques légumes qu'elles
ont eu du mal à semer et récolter mais
elles ont tout fait pour leurs familles
dans ces ruelles une femme une femme ont
sari bleu et blanc arpentent les rues là
aussi avec son baluchon à la recherche
de quelques bouts de pain pour nourrir
toutes les personnes dont elle a la
charge
dans ce brouhaha innommable par les
klaxons des taxis par les klaxons des
pousse-pousse par les aboiements de
quelques chiens
cette femme marche et un moment donné
dans un carrefour
elles sont blancs entendre un cri elle
semble entendre des pleurs elle se
demande qui s'est bien entendu mais avec
tous et klaxons elle continue son chemin
et puis prise de remords elle revient en
arrière
hélas elle s'approche de secret
elle sera proche de ses pleurs et tombe
nez à nez dans sur une décharge sur une
décharge un tas d'ordures sur une
décharge dans lesquels dans laquelle les
ports viennent chercher à manger
les chiens eux aussi élévage continuent
leur nuit elle est attirée par ce pleurs
par ses pleurs et là elle s'approche et
elle voit un petit bébé tout frêle tous
vulnérables qui pleure il l'a ni
couverture et il pleut il est là il est
seul ayant comme amis des animaux
elle le prend dans ses bras la mayotte
avec son sari et à ce moment là elle
s'aperçoit qu'au tour de son coût autour
du cou de baie du bébé il y a un bout de
ficelle avec son prénom
robin elle s'aperçoit aussi que sur son
bras il y a deux inscriptions
la première c'est le prénom de sa maman
chou badra qui en hindi veut dire la
bonne mère et puis au dessous est écrit
la date de sa naissance le 9 septembre
elle le prend elle n'en mayotte et elle
va le conduire dans un lieu sûr dans ce
lieu qui est un de ces orphelinats nous
sommes le 19 septembre 1982 cette femme
senard teresa ce bébé c'est moi j'ai
vécu onze mois dans cet orphelinat
n'ayons pour nourriture que de l'eau et
du sucre à cause de la pauvre
côté j'ai donc beaucoup souffert de
malnutrition et 11 mois après j'ai eu la
chance d'être adoptés d'être adoptée par
une famille française habitant dans la
drôme qui n'a pas pu avoir d'enfants et
qui ont adopté cinq enfants deux indiens
deux français et un haïtien
l'année dernière j'ai eu pour la
première fois la chance de repartir en
ondes et d'aller aider cet orphelinat
qui m'a donné la vie et j'ai rencontré
une soeur qui était présente avec mère
teresa lorsqu'elle m'a récupéré et nous
sommes allés liés ensemble et registre
sur lequel j'étais marqué et sur les
registres
voilà ce qu il était écrit dès le début
robin s'est battu pour vivre et je crois
que je continue maintenant à me battre
la vie est un combat
on n'a rien sans rien je n'ai jamais eu
une seule seconde de haine envers mes
parents qui m'ont abandonné parce que
dans le mot abandon il ya le mot dont
ils m'ont donné la vie à moi maintenant
de la transmettre
j'ai eu une enfance et une adolescence
dans cette famille qui m'a redonné une
dignité humaine mais j'ai galéré parce
que je n'ai jamais été douée dans les
études jamais j'avais beaucoup de
difficulté
j'ai failli ne pas avoir mon bac je suis
alors rattrapage pour la voir et j'ai
rencontré une personne
j'étais en seconde à de mes professeurs
au lycée un jour m'a dit ils vont tout
le monde
il m'a dit emmanuel tu n'as pas les
capacités intellectuelles pour faire des
études
voilà ce que je te propose je le propose
de faire groupe dans un hôtel
comme tu ne sais rien faire de ta tête
peut-être - qui saura faire quelque
chose de tes mains
jamais je l' ai pensé une seule seconde
du mal de ce prof
parce que je lui dis merci parce que
grâce à lui ce dont j'ai appris c'est de
faire de ses faiblesses
une force une force qui permet d'avancer
une force qui permet de se battre une
force qui permet de combattre
finalement une force qui simplement
permet d'être soi même
lorsque j'ai commencé mes études de
philosophie à lyon j'ai fondé une
association pour la visite des enfants
ayant une maladie pour la visite des
personnes étant en prison pour la visite
des personnes est âgée et un jour dans
une maison de retraite
j'ai rencontré un couple extraordinaire
il avait 81 18 ans elle en avait 96 et
durant nos discussions
lui ne parlait plus et est grabataire et
elle continuait à parler et toute la
journée ils se regardaient lent et
l'autre dans le salon de la maison de
retraite et un jour je demande à la dame
je lui dis aimez vous toujours votre
époux et sa réponse a illuminé ma vie et
je dirais c'était une très très belle
leçon de vie puisqu'elle m'a dit vous
savez je n'aurais jamais fini des mets
mon époux parce que je n'aurais jamais
fini de le découvrir à 96 ans nous dire
ça et j'ai aimé cette rencontre parce
que non seulement elle a illuminé ma vie
mal m'a fait comprendre combien la
rencontre est une richesse
le philosophe emmanuel levinas parlera
de l'épiphanie du visage il dira quand
tu vois une personne ce qui est le plus
important c'est son visage ce qui est le
plus important dans son visage c'est son
oeil ce qui est le plus important dans
son oeil
c'est sa pupille
parce qu'au-delà de la pupille de
l'homme se trouve son véritable mystère
je n'aurais jamais fini de l'aimer parce
que je n'aurais jamais fini de le
découvrir
on s'approche de ce mystère et
permettez-moi de de vous dire osons la
rencontre osons cette rencontre de
l'intergénération osons cette rencontre
sortons de nous pour aller à l'autre
pour aller vers l'autre et acceptons
l'hôtel qu'il est mais avant d'accepter
l'hôtel qui les font d'abord s'accepter
soi-même et c'est dans l'acceptation de
soi même que le terreau de la qualité
humaine n'est la première fois que je
rencontre mes étudiants à l'université
le premier jour je leur demande leur
pose une question par écrit
je le redis écrivez moi quel est pour
vous votre plus belle qualité
tout le monde parle des défauts je dis
quel est votre plus belle qualité
ils me rendent les papiers je leur dis
bah voilà vous avez écrit vos plus
belles qualités
mettez la au service des autres ainsi
vous passerez non seulement une bonne
année mais une belle vie parce que je
crois que si chacune et chacun d'entre
nous mettions notre plus belle qualité
au service des autres la violence
n'existerait plus les guerres
n'existerait plus vous savez on n'est
pas responsable de la vie qu'on a reçu
on est responsable de la vie que l'on a
à transmettre
on n'est pas responsable du visage que
l'on a mais on est responsable du visage
que l'on offre mrt rosa disait ne laisse
jamais une personne partir sans qu'elle
ne soit plus heureuse que lorsqu'elle
est arrivée un simple sourire peut
transformer l'homme un simple regard
changeons de regard sur l'homme et le
monde ira mieux
changeons de regard sur le monde et le
monde d'hier
avec toutes ses faiblesses avec toutes
ces moments difficiles que j'ai pu
passer
j'ai appris à dire merci merci pour ce
que la vie m'a donné
merci pour ce que la vie m'a apporté à
mon tour malgré mes faiblesses à mon
tour malgré ma vulnérabilité à mon tour
de l'offrir aux autres
j'aime beaucoup cette phrase de
catherine de sienne qui disait si tu
deviens qui tu es tu mettra le feu au
monde
alors oui devenant toujours de plus en
plus qui nous sommes acceptons nous tels
que nous sommes
regardons l'autre acceptons l'hô tel
qu'il est et non pas comme tel qu'on
voudrait qu'il soit et surtout si je
devais ce soir vous laisser une seule
phrase alors ce serait celle-ci creuse
le coeur de l'homme tué trouvera un
soleil je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]